it's called the ba2 variant and it has
meant we're far from done with covid as
it spreads fast around the world
millions of chinese citizens on total
lockdown in shanghai mass mandates
reimposed in philadelphia extended for
all air and train travel across the u.s
with dozens of the washington elite
testing positive after attending a fancy
dinner there last week so to help us
understand how to deal with all this
what to expect next we're joined by dr
william shafter from the vanderbilt
university school of medicine one of the
country's leading authorities on
infectious diseases he hopes to advise
federal regulators and tonight he's here
to help advise all of us dr shafter
thanks for being here what's your
thought on this new variant and how much
of a worry should we be
well hello bryant this new variant
actually is uh something else again as
we like to say
it's uh the son of omicron you can think
of it that way closely related to that
omicron variant
it's very highly contagious even more
contagious than its parent
however it does not make you more
seriously ill
and fortunately
our vaccines continue to be able to
protect us against severe disease now
that said
this variant can infect you even though
you're well vaccinated but you'll get
either almost no symptoms or the
symptoms that are equivalent to a bad
cold so it's spreading very widely
causing a lot of cases but fortunately
not very many hospitalizations
people at risk for hospitalizations
still the folks who haven't been
vaccinated
and people who are incompletely
vaccinated you know if you've had those
first two doses you need the third
we've seen in philadelphia they're
reimposing mask mandates is that going
to work around this country given all
the resistance to mandates we've seen so
far
i think the receptivity to reintroducing
mass mandates is going to vary a lot
across the country it may well work in
philadelphia but i don't think it would
be well received in my neck of the woods
so
i think we have different cultures in
different parts of the country and we'll
see how well it's accepted in
philadelphia might help
dampen down the spread of this variant
in in that city
dr schaffner a question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
doctor there's still no vaccine approved
for children under the age of five how
urgent is that in this fight against
kovid and can you give us any insights
into why the holdup why it's so
difficult
well rhonda the hold up is just that the
studies are still proceeding it's taking
longer for those studies to be completed
than frankly many of us had anticipated
so hold on
it's still in the works
would we like to have it sure
we would have a segment of the
population parents who would go out and
immediately get their children
vaccinated those very young ones
but we still have to persuade many other
parents to vaccinate children who are
already eligible for vaccination
and the fact that cases are diminishing
really has slowed down our national
vaccination effort now we'll just have
to keep
giving information out and trying to
encourage folks
dr shafter let me follow up on that do
you think the mandates the requirements
the demands that people get vaccinated
in some way uh backfired there's still a
huge number of americans who are
resisting uh getting vaccinated
yeah brian it was plus minus
i think that any number of things could
have been done better
mandates have helped they clearly
increased vaccination in large segments
of the population
in health care for example
but they also among some people just had
them double down in their disinclination
to get vaccinated
the people who are really anti-vaccine
i think probably will remain that way
it's the people who are skeptical
hesitant uncomfortable whom we would
still like to reach
dr schaffner over the course of this
pandemic i guess is now
less of a pandemic than it was
you have been able to
avoid being inflicted with it as i have
but uh for most people there's a sense
like it's everyone's got to get it at
some
point well you know i think many many
people will get infected particularly
with this new
ba2 variant
however there's still lots of people who
are being very very careful
older persons people with underlying
illnesses heart disease lung disease
diabetes is so common
if you're medically obese all of those
people as well as people who are immune
compromised
they know that they are at increased
risk of hospitalization even if they've
been vaccinated so many of those people
are still hunkering down
wearing their masks in public and we
need to support them when they do that
finally would you say the pandemic is
over
well i wouldn't say over brian but
clearly the pandemic is on the wane and
now we're
just about entering uh phase two the
endemic phase and by that we mean the
virus is not going to disappear it will
smolder in our population in some way
going forward and we'll have to deal
with that
and that may well require it's not
recommended yet but
a periodic booster uh vaccination
perhaps with a retailer vaccine brought
up to date
sounds a whole lot like what we do with
flu exactly well dr william schaffner as
always thanks so much for being with us
here tonight
my pleasure you bet up next this week's
winners and losers in the media the good
and the bad at cnn you're watching brian
ross investigates on the long crime
trial network
this week's winners and losers in the
media as chosen by the editors of
mediaite and we're joined by aidan
mclaughlin who's the editor-in-chief of
mediaite which like the law and crime
trial network is part of the dan abrams
media group naden you've chosen as your
winner this week someone most americans
may never have heard of david sasloff
that's right most americans may never
have heard of him but he's now one of
the most powerful people in hollywood
and in news
as the new ceo of warner bros discovery
a new company which merged on friday
and now has basically wedded uh warner
media which uh owns cnn hbo and a slew
of other networks with discovery um
which is itself a massive entertainment
company the the combined company now has
36 000 employees all whom fall under
david zaslav uh now he's been the
subject of glowing reporting in the last
week um probably more so than i've seen
for for any other executive in recent
memory um cb cnbc recently published a
story that described him as high eq
an incredibly compelling executive with
a lot of friends in hollywood and in
news
axios published a similar story that
extolled his virtues as an executive
that said he has a lot on his plate now
despite uh the glowing coverage uh the
company the newly merged company has 55
billion dollars in debt uh that it now
has to pay down um and there's a lot of
synergy between the two companies as
well
reports are that he's looking to
eliminate
about three billion dollars
off the top of the balance sheet uh for
warner brothers discovery um so he has a
lot of work to do we'll see if any of
that press starts to change in the next
couple weeks and we'll see how popular
he remains as he cuts jobs and costs
that's right and you know we had mediate
we reported on his first meetings with
cnn and hbo uh in cnn's new york and
washington d.c headquarters
and so far our sources who were attended
those meetings at cnn uh have said that
uh they're they're pretty confident uh
and pretty pleased with what david
zaslav has said so far um and he sort of
reassured them he praised their ukraine
coverage um
but once you know cuts start to come
whether they come to cnn cnn plus uh the
streaming service that just launched two
weeks ago and is reported to already be
having some troubles with sign ups um i
think some of that sentiment is going to
start to change we're just gonna have to
wait and see and this week's loser the
former cnn anchor chris cuomo uh
allegedly planting a puff story on his
own program on cnn to stave off a woman
who might have made an allegation
against him about sexual abuse here's
that little clip that's where we work
came in now this business has tons of
special programs including one for
veterans it pairs them with mentors and
gives them a sponsored workspace and
then even helps them with networking for
capital and otherwise so thanks to
wework carries company which makes
sandals out of recycled tires booming
so the allegation aiden as you know is
that he arranged for that puff piece on
wework to be aired to stave off
someone's going to make an allegation
against him right so you'll recall when
chris cuomo was fired from cnn back in
december
cnn said that not only was it because uh
he advised his brother uh new york
governor andrew cuomo on his own
allegations but they also said that in
their investigation their internal
investigation uh into what happened
there that a new allegation against
chris cuomo himself an allegation of
sexual misconduct came to light now that
allegation as we know now from reporting
um was from a junior staffer at abc who
worked with chris cuomo and
a her lawyer sent a letter to cnn saying
that chris cuomo actually sexually
assaulted her at abc that is the claim
uh cnn
chris cuomo has denied those allegations
through a rep
one of the big allegations has come out
now in this video which has just
resurfaced that woman claims that chris
cuomo ran this puff piece about wework
where she then later worked in order to
try and silence her allegation against
him back in 2017 when the metoo movement
was really at its height it was weeks
after matt lauer had been um ousted uh
from nbc uh and there were a bunch of
other allegations floating around at the
time so if true it would be a stunning
allegation and certainly the puff piece
does not look good for chris cuomo right
now a serious allegation and on that
case what has mr cuomo said about it
quickly he's never said anything
publicly but his spokesperson denied the
allegation of sexual assault uh to the
new york times when they asked him about
it back in february if true a very
serious allegation against him crossing
all kinds of journalism ethics lines
all right aidan mclaughlin thank you so
much for being here and thanks all of
you for watching we'll see you again
here next week on the long crime trial
network
you